hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and in this presentation i'm going to be
talking about the difference between
time based charts and tick based charts
specifically as it applies to our new
indicator the order flows flow breaks
now you know i do realize some of you
are already familiar with tick based
charts you know it's nothing new it's
been out there for a while but you know
for some of the newer traders they may
not be familiar with what a tick based
chart really is and how it differs from
say a volume based chart
or your traditional tick bait sorry your
traditional time based chart now
earlier this week we released a new
order flow indicator called flow breaks
right and what it does is it looks for a
combination of aggressive trading in a
direction followed by passive trading in
that same direction
however a question i have received a few
times is what market or chart type does
it work best on so today i'm going to
dive into that topic a little bit deeper
now
time based charts are the most commonly
used charts among traders right you have
the one minute chart the five-minute
chart the 15-minute chart the 30-minute
chart the hourly the four-hour obviously
the daily you know those are all based
on time so you know after
the end of five minutes of trading boom
the bar is closed and you start a new
one so whatever happens within that bar
happens now there are other types of
charts which are
useful as well right and today i'm going
to talk about the tick based chart again
you know the tick based chart has been
around for a long time
it's nothing new but i want to show you
some of the differences that you're
going to see on a tick based chart
versus
a time based chart
so again while a time based chart
time based bar on a time chart is
constructed based on what trades in a
specific time period a tick based bar on
a tick chart is a predetermined number
of transactions in a bar
so in other words
right if you have a 100 tick chart each
bar would have 100 transactions
but here's where it gets interesting
each transaction could be a different
volume
now most of the time the volumes are one
or two contracts
you know especially nowadays with the
execution out goes you know they really
got ways of chopping up a big order into
small orders to sort of hide what
they're doing in the market however you
know obviously once it trades trades but
there will be times where bigger volume
trades right like a 50 contracts or 100
contract trade that just goes through in
one clip so while you have a 100 tick
chart each bar's individual
volume will vary one bar could have a
volume of 110
while the next bar can have
you know a volume of 353. so
the important thing to remember is not
all transactions are the same right
again
one transaction could be for one
contract whereas the next con the next
transaction could be for 85 contracts
okay so it's going to vary and you know
again the difference between say a tick
based chart and a volume based chart
volume based chart is based on a number
of a volume in a bar so if you have a
100 volume
bar chart
each bar has 100 volume whereas if you
have a 100 tick chart
the volume in each bar can vary
so as an order flow trader when you see
big volume at a price or prices go
through that should get your attention
to dig deeper into what is going on and
possibly take a trade
now
after all what is happening is you have
regular order flow coming in and all of
a sudden a burst of volume appears for
whatever reason that is important to see
so let me give you a real life example
right our new tool flow brakes looks for
heavier than normal volume coming in on
both sides of the market
think of it like a volume breakout you
know hence the name flow brakes case
you're wondering why it's called flow
breaks so if you're looking at a normal
tick based chart in this case i'm going
to look at a 100 tick wheat chart
do you think knowing where the volume
breakouts would be helpful right this is
a normal 100
tick wheat chart right and you can see
it's you know it's gone up double top
come off gone back up
going back down
so
as a trader right
you sort of want to know where the heavy
volume is coming in and
not just where is coming in but which
direction
is that trading going on
and flow breaks will highlight that to
you right now whether you're using flow
breaks or whether you're using a normal
footprint chart you know it doesn't
matter right really as an order
filtrator
you want to see where that volume is
coming in and if you don't have a way to
determine hey there's heavy volume
by volume coming in here you're going to
miss that move up or you know heavy cell
volume here followed by heavy by volume
heavy cell volume to catch this nice
move down from 770 you know all the way
down into the 750s you know as an order
flow trader that's really what you're
focusing in on is
the big volume that's coming into the
market not just the regular um
transactions that are just you know the
market facilitating trade right you want
to be alerted
or notice when the big directional
volumes are coming in because that's
what's ultimately going to move the
market
so the most important thing you have to
keep in mind with tick charts is that
you can't use the same amount of ticks
for all markets okay so for markets that
trade lesser volume you know i'd start
at 100 ticks you know for example wheat
gold
ultra bonds right yeah i would those
markets don't trade as much as
the
e-minis or the mes or the nq so you know
you can't use a thousand ticks that
you'd probably use you know in nq
um in wheat because the volume is
much less right just same with gold and
ultra bonds right since those markets
are inherently
have less volume unless they inherently
have less money they do have less volume
you can't use the same amount of kicks
as you would for other markets so you
know i sort of have it categorized by
sort of groups of markets you know sort
of the
low volume markets the average volume
markets and the heavy volume markets now
doesn't mean you can't trade a low
volume market of course you can right
you know to be honest the way some of
these what i would consider quote a low
volume market today you know back in the
90s that was considered heavy volume
already so
let's take a look at
some charts here just sort of give you
an idea so i'll pull up
a chart so this is
an mes chart but i was just talk about
the low volume markets right the the
wheats the gold the ultra bonds all
right um go back to my chart here we go
i'll just uh well i'll just use this so
this is a 1000 tick mes chart okay
mes trades
you know over a million contracts a day
okay but if i was going to look at
another market you know we'll call it
we'll just go with wheat right i can't
necessarily really do very much with
wheat on a thousand tick chart
because
you know this is the whole day of
yesterday right right here whereas
since they reopened last night to eight
you know whatever 8 40 in the morning
you know you only got maybe 10 bars
right whereas on the 1000
tick mes chart right this is just you
know since 8 30 this morning right here
you've got you know more bars than you
had yesterday in the
um in the wheat so you know with wheat i
would go back i wouldn't use a 1 000
tick chart i would use you know 100 okay
so this is this morning you know in the
weeds right just scroll back since last
night to reopen here you know for the
first couple hours after the reopen up
until
you know midnight
there's not much activity right you only
got one two three four five six you know
about
10 bars 12 bars it's because there's not
much activity going on there's not much
trading going on so why you got lesser
bars so the more activity you have the
more bars you're going to get
okay so this is
right this is yesterday
in the weeds okay again you know that
nice
move down some nice move downs you know
really what you want to be doing you
know
is you know following the action of the
market it's going up okay boom boom boom
bye bye bye you know people will say
well you got this buy signal that failed
here really you know when you're using
a tool like the flow brakes you're going
to take the first signal all right
you're not looking to buy after the
market had just put in a big rally you
get a buy signal up here okay just as
you take the first sell signal here you
know here you've got a bunch of cell
signals you know don't don't
take this last one say oh you know what
this one failed well really you should
be getting long
early you know that's the whole point of
looking at order flow is to get in early
to a trade if you just you know say you
just turned on your computer right here
at 10 30
well look to the left a little bit and
see well i just had this big move down
do i really want to be taking this move
after you just had almost a 20 sell-off
no you probably don't because how much
is left to that move i mean it can go
down to hit limit down but then
you know where would you rather be
looking to get long you know after a 20
cent move down
or get short after 20 cent move down but
again you know that that just deals with
market context um you know let's take a
look at another market gold okay gold
this is a 100 tick chart
again you see this nice trend down some
short short short short short yeah you
do have some you know it did look like
some buying came in here to you know to
bounce it back up but it didn't happen
right so you still got some moves down
um you know in the gold right you can
see how it's starting to put in a nice
rally here off that off that bottom
um ultra bonds ultra bonds is a great
contract to trade
um let me just scrunch up this chart a
bit here
you know here's a sell signal right here
uh let's go back here
you know going back since this morning
seven o'clock
you know i mean ultrabons you know
liquidity
pre-new york hours you know isn't always
that great but you're seeing some nice
moves here right here's a nice move down
it's another nice move down it's a nice
move up all right it doesn't look like
much here but this is what i moved from
you know the 0.608 area all the way up
until
18. but this was a nice move here it's
almost a full point here 187
down to almost 186. again another nice
big move here
so
you know when you're looking at these
markets you know understand the volumes
of the market and
how it trades because again you can't
trade every market using the exact same
tick chart you know when you're using a
time based chart yeah you could use a
time based chart you know the same one
minute that you would use on ultra bonds
that you would use in mes or mnq or ym
okay
but when you're dealing with ticks
you're dealing with the number of
transactions right and so
some markets have less transactions all
right so just you know bear that in mind
now
again as you start analyzing markets
with more overall volume like crude oil
mini dow mes you're going to need a
higher amount of ticks to make up your
chart
because the more active the market the
more trading is going on so a 100 tick
chart in mes would be equivalent to
trading a five second chart basically
let's go back to the chart
and
let's put up uh
where's my nes here we'll pull up the
mes chart
all right and
put the crosshairs on
okay so you can see right like from this
bar right here right it's 8 46 36 8 46
8 seconds
you know 41 let's go here it keeps
moving um
example here 844 58 845 double oh 840
845.07 you know this is a 100 tick chart
and basically you're getting a bar every
one or two seconds right but if you were
to bump it up to
a thousand right now you're giving the
chance the market to have more
transactions all right you're going to
see here right from this high 8 40 52
841.09 still a little fast um
841 26
37 52. so now you know a 1000 tick chart
is basically more or less a 15 20 second
chart you're trading okay so maybe you
don't want to use a 1 000 tick maybe you
want to make make it uh 2 000 right so
or 1 500 you know so what you do is you
just open that up you can adjust it here
you can add
um
you know whatever volume you want
you know
2 000
right now again you know this is 2 000
here
um so you could
i i didn't save configure
tick
add
two thousand
if
hopefully it'll work
there we go
you know 2 000 here so
now you're seeing
the 2000 tick chart okay
open it up
you know now it's a little bit more
consistent you know it's about
eight forty thirty seconds eight forty
one oh nine
thirty seven
oh eight so it's actually coming in
about a thirty second chart
okay it's a nice move here nice move
here
all right so
understand the market that you're
trading because again you can't use the
same
tick
amount on every market right so you know
if you're using a high volume market
you're probably going to want to use
a higher tick
amount
now
i know some traders like to use an
amount of ticks based on fib numbers 233
987.
honestly
i don't think it really gives you an
edge over any other number right i think
i say well it's a fib number okay you
know and then fibs are magical you know
fine you know i
that's your prerogative you could use
whatever you want honestly you know all
i know is when i go to the barber shop
and get a haircut i don't say uh you
know take off
what is
the number um you know they don't take
take off 31.8 or whatever percent off
the side you know when you cook right
you use certain measurements but you
know hey whatever if that works for you
it's sort of like the guys that think
they've they've got an edge by using
instead of instead everyone's using a
five minute chart so i'm gonna use a
three and a half minute chart give me an
edge over them you know okay okay you
know honestly it's
you're just taking the information and
you're just putting it looking at it
through a different lens so
that's me okay that's that's my thoughts
um really what you're looking for is the
volume burst right which would appear if
you're using a 199 tick chart or a 200
or 233 or 250 tick chart any of which
honestly work nicely in in crude oil in
case you're wondering um where crude oil
sort of fits in here so let's pull up um
let's pull up a crude chart
okay well let me go in here first before
i do that i'll add some of these numbers
i got a i got 200 300 all right i'll add
go to tick here
um
i'll add you know just some random
numbers 190 well
random but uh
we'll go 199 right i've already got a
200 i'll move that up
[Music]
and i'll add a
okay
move you up
i'll add a uh
250.
move you up and then lastly let's add a
225.
get some numbers just sort of more or
less the same again what's the
difference between
the 199 and 200 one transaction
225 233 yeah of course you get a
thousand lot pop in any you know between
that
eight lot eight eight transaction
difference 233 250 more or less the same
um
so
do it crude here crude
okay
oops make sure i got the right
yeah okay so it's 2000 tick chart um
all right so you know start with the 199
tick chart
okay so you got that move up here
to move down
um i'll tell you what i want to do here
instead of
okay this is a 200 tick chart
basically more or less
slightly
different right you got this on the 199
you got this big
red candle down here you don't have it
here sort of
you got this red red red um
let's take a look at
225 closer to the
more or less the same
go with the
fib
okay it's the same more or less to the
225 this is 233 this is 225 225 does get
you in a little bit earlier there
um
it says 233 still catching this move
down from you know the
75 80 area
down to here and uh
lastly let's just throw in the 250.
you know so you don't have to buy here
on the 250. now again you know as you go
from the 199 again that's just a number
i could have thrown in 189 it'd probably
be a little bit more similar
but you know 199 the 200
225 233
250 very similar
you know again it's
depends on on your tree you know if if
you're a big fib person by all means you
use the 233. now
me i prefer
you know whole numbers you know 200 100
250 500 you know
equal intervals
um i i don't jump around
you know i don't i don't try to curve
fit everything like come out with 189 or
you know find out oh the 169 chart tick
chart is is the best i mean
it can in the short term it may work but
uh you know or
as you know if you've ever done back
testing right there's always the problem
of curve fitting something so just bear
that in mind okay
now why would you want to use a tick
based chart instead of a time based
chart well i don't look at it as i got
to use tick based or time based i use
both i look at both you don't have to
give up your time based chart if that's
what you're using or your high kanashi
chart
add a tick based chart to give you a
different perspective on the same market
because you know even though you're you
know you're looking at
you know this is your
crude oil right your
tick chart you know if you have a minute
based chart obviously it's going to look
much different
right you do have the cell here it's
just giving you
a different perspective on the same
market
all right because sometimes you know you
might be
thinking you know should i take this
short here well you know on the
minute-based chart yeah i've got my
bearish signal i'm on my tick based
chart yeah i got my bearish signal um
you know it just it gives you a just a
different look you know it's like heaven
excuse me it's like having a second
opinion
on the market so you don't have to give
one up to use the other one
now
is there a perfect tick amount for
everyone to use no there's not it really
depends on the market you're trading and
your own risk tolerance but i do believe
there is a right tick amount for you to
use
right and that's going to come down to
you
sort of doing the the leg work right i
could recommend what i use um you know
i'm a different type of trader than many
people i'm a very short-term trader so
you know
while i was showing you you know um
wheat you know on a
100 tick chart
right some of you may not want to use a
100 tick chart maybe you want to use
you know because you want to be a little
bit faster um
i don't think i got 50 on this one um
let's add it in here show you how it
get in here
five zero
click okay
where is it down at the bottom move you
up
top click apply
okay so
you know maybe you want to use the you
know a 50 tick chart instead right
because you're a faster trader
you know obviously this is 8 30 this is
when the market opens so you've seen a
lot of trades going through so you've
seen a lot of bars but as things sort of
slowed down you got a nice buy here a
cell didn't work out then you got a nice
cell right here
into the buy that just sort of went
sideways on you um you know but again
you
look at it you know over previous days
to see how the movements are if it's
something that suits your risk tolerance
um you know or not and another way to
determine you know should i be using
this chart is sort of get you know look
at the time intervals because if you
know on some markets a
50 tick chart or 100 tick chart
would be equivalent to trading a 15 or a
30 second chart which you may not want
to do right because sometimes it could
be a lot of volume
um coming through for for whatever
reason so you know for example here's
you know just
just look at the time right 9 30 and 13
seconds
double o
12. so you know a 50 tick chart in wheat
is more or less equivalent to about a 15
to 30 second chart you know
figure that out what you want to be
trading especially you know when you're
in the indices obviously you're not
going to use a 50 tick chart in you know
mes because the ticks are going to be
you know fast and furious you'd want to
use something
you know
a bit higher i mean you're seeing here
right
856 41 42
43.
you know a 50 tick chart you know yes is
basically a one second chart you know
you probably don't want to be doing that
you know you you'd want to start using
higher numbers
right by understanding you know what the
market is right even if you're on a
a 500 tick chart
okay what's a 500 tick chart basically
equivalent to 20 seconds 24 30. this is
about a five 500 tick charges
you know about a five second chart more
or less
all right so yeah you go then you go
higher one hundred one thousand two
thousand but you know ultimately at the
end of the day it's about
finding the right tick amount for you
and your style of trading because
everyone's got a different style of
trading okay
and you know once you understand that
then stick with it right but you should
use a tick based chart to complement
your other existing chart that you're
already using and you're successful with
now if you're interested in that flow
breaks indicator which i used in this
presentation just go to
www.flowbreaks.com
to get started and hopefully you found
this video
useful you know if you did give it a
thumbs up
leave your comments below
thank you and have a great day